because a great anecdote doesn't leave
people speechless it leaves them
competing
to tell a better version of the same
thing
and that's when a real writer just
starts realizing okay there's a pattern
and that can be turned into something
really big what if there was a place you
could go
and get into a fight as casually as you
would go ask someone to dance
what would the rules be for that place
and i would
take the book and go through and use a
highlighter
to highlight all the stuff like i want
to use i want to use this i want to use
that because the book has got a lot of
stuff and it can't all go into the movie
right
and then sit down and stare at a blank
screen for hours on end
and be full of fear i start thinking
about well what are what are some key
scenes that i feel like
would be in this project whether it's
the climax or
some other part of the film and i try to
write those scenes first
out of order as i call it the scent of
blood
what happens is you are in it now
and you didn't start unfaded
it started as a uh it started on an
afternoon at work
two o'clock in the afternoon right after
lunch and i wanted to write a short
story
and i wanted to experiment using rules
as a transitional device
so i just had to come up with seven
rules
just arbitrary seven rules what if
what if there was a place you could go
and get into a fight as casually as you
would go
ask someone to dance what would the
rules be for that place
so i came up with these seven rules that
would allow me to just
jump around in time and place and topic
uh as long as i came back in and touched
on a rule
and i wrote that story in half an hour
and that became chapter six of fight
club it was the first
short story i ever sold to a magazine
this is your first night at fight club
you have to fight i had gone on a
vacation i've been hiking and camping
and i had gotten into a really big fight
with some people
over noise at night in the woods you
know some people who just had to camp
right next to our camp
just had to bring some huge radio up to
3000 feet on the pacific crest trail
and have a some big blowout party in the
middle of the night
and i came back to work at the end of my
vacation with my face just
bashed my face was so awful and so
trashed that nobody
would acknowledge it because to
acknowledge it somehow they would have
to find out something about my private
life they just did not want to know
and so for three months as my face
slowly changed color eventually coming
back to white
people would look at at my chest and
they would talk to my adam's apple
and they would say so how was your
weekend did you do anything interesting
and i'd be looking at them with two huge
black eyes saying no
how about you if you looked bad enough
no one would dare ask you
what you did with your free time i
showed this already my man here
you liked it didn't you it was
such a miserable time in my life i was
right out of college
and i had a job doing something i i
hated doing
and i was so desperate that somebody
said come join my church
and when you're right out of college
you've left behind all of your social
structure
you've lost all your friends and i was
so desperate to be with people that i
went to church
and the church had a giving tree and it
was covered with ornaments and you just
plucked an
ornament and one ornament that i plucked
said take a hospice
patient on a date the idea was that you
would
go to a hospice and you would ask out
someone who was dying
and you would take them to see the ocean
for the last time
and more often than not it was will you
take me to my support group
i need a ride so i would drive them to
their support group
and i would have to stay at the support
group and no matter how much i tried to
hide
people would assume that i had whatever
everyone had
and there was no polite way of saying
whoa
whoa whoa no don't have hepatitis
good for you but not me and so i started
to kind of
create this narrative in which a man
attends these groups because the next
day when i went back up to work
i felt really good that no matter how
shitty and boring
my life it turned out with my journalism
degree and all my student loans i still
owed
at least i didn't have cancer when
people think you're dying and they
really really listen to you instead of
just
instead of just waiting for their turn
to speak and can you talk a little bit
about the phenomenon of
the sort of popularity of it and then
and then the sort of i guess a lot of
people have
started fight clubs i guess in the in
the aftermath of it
and that goes back to the cacophony
society because cacophony
was basically an organization of people
who had really boring jobs
they were letter carriers for the post
office there were
bookstore clerks at powell's there were
people who had really you know
very structured hourly job lives and
they needed a way to have chaos in their
lives
for a very structured like window of
time
you know if we do this kind of a theme
party we can be crazy we can be insane
anarchists from four o'clock
until midnight on saturday night
and so it was a way of having completely
structured chaos in your life
and being able to schedule that every
week
kind of an experiential potluck because
people would host it people would come
up with concepts
the way you did when you were kids and
you would play a game
okay the boards the boards are safe but
the ground is lava
so if you touch the ground and you would
do that you just arbitrarily come up
with rules
you know the first rule of fight club is
you don't talk you just
come up with a rule and another rule and
you invent the game
instantly you have the freedom the
authority to do that
and and cacophony let us do that every
week
and give up our boring lives for two or
three hours
fifth rule one fight at a time fellas
fortunately i sort of stylistically
sort of melded with chuck palanik and um
put in the stuff where i put in my own
material it seemed to mix
with where i was using stuff from the
book
but the main thing was is this
structurally i had to put together
something that worked as a screen story
and i would take the book and go through
and use a
highlighter to highlight all the stuff
like i want to use i want to use this i
want to use that because the book has
got a lot of stuff
and it can't all go into the movie right
so
um i would i would do that
and then sort of use that as a guide and
then
sit down and stare at a blank screen for
hours on end
and be full of fear
well any novel has the advantage of
being able to describe
both external behavior and internal
behavior
as well as any exposition that can be
ladled on
right screenplays don't have that luxury
at all it's
watching external behavior so
even if you're faithful to a novel and a
scene
feels like it's faithful to a novel
if it works on screen you have made
changes to it
because you are not using an internal
narrative
to uh describe the interior process
and so i i just say that it's the thing
that comes down with adaptations
is you have to work as hard as you do on
an original script
because at the end of the day what
people want that you're turning it into
is a workable screenplay right if you
turn into a producer
director or studio executive an ungodly
mess
right that's really faithful to the
novel
you're going to be replaced by another
rider
i ran until my muscles burned and my
veins pump battery acid
now do you how do you find the voice of
a character like as a writer
i mean i know every writer is a little
bit different but how do you find your
voice
and your characters well i'll put two of
them together in the house just start
writing scenes
um i like to do what's i call it writing
outside the script and there's various
forms it takes one is
scenes that are well there are scenes
that are not going to be in the script
and sometimes they're just scenes that i
put in any situation
and sometimes there are scenes that
would come before the story of the
script starts
and sometimes i interview the characters
where it's
you know i type jim and i type my first
question
i type the character name the answer and
i
try to goad them provoke them get them
angry then get them
you know suddenly talking in a
sentimental way about some memory or
something and then
get them joking and laughing and
basically just
get them all over the range with
questions
and um you know it starts off it's it's
very very mechanical at first
but they sort of start to come alive in
an interview
things you own end up owning you during
the the
the writing over the crafting of it did
you ever suffer kind of a roadblock or
any any type of writer's block
in the in the in the in just the the
crafting of it or do you ever
have you ever experienced that oh yeah
yeah yeah um
that happens a lot either before i start
something
um which is really in a way kind of
worse
because there's nothing that you're
right blocked from that you need to get
back to
right you just you're blocked and you're
not starting something
but in either case what i try to do is
my experiments like my interviews with
the characters
um i also find that if it's an idea and
i pretty much know the idea but i feel
really blocked about how to
shape it i start thinking about well
what are what are some key scenes that i
feel like would be in this project
whether it's the climax or some other
part of the film
and i try to write those scenes first
out of order
and what happens is i call it the scent
of blood
what happens is you are
in it now and you didn't start on fade
in
right but you're you're in the script
and it can kind of grow out from
inside instead of page one right
and that's i found it to be very
effective to get through
blocked so like i i find a lot of blocks
happen sequentially right while you're
going in linear fashion
and you just can't figure out what the
connective tissue
or the transition is right at this part
of the story
i say skip it right
go over to this part where you really
have some feeling
and write that and i think that's a good
way of staying in it
you met me at a very strange time in my
life but unless you're ruffling feathers
even within workshop
you're not going far enough you know i
loved writing that line in fight club
where tyler and marla have sex for the
first time and
the most romantic thing that marla can
say is i want to have your baby
so what is the inverse so of course
marla
turns to him and she says i hope i got
pregnant because i really want to have
your abortion
and that's the line that the movie
studio went around and around and even
brad pitt
said you know my mom's gonna see this
movie i
i don't want her to see this line
and they shot that scene with so many
different substitute lines
and then finally fincher wrote the line
and helena bonham carter says i haven't
been
[ __ ] like that since grade school and
at that point 20th century fox said can
we switch
it back to the abortion line
and so unless you're always kind of
pushing to kind of
you know until you get some pushback you
don't feel like you're pushing hard
enough
and so push back is not a bad thing it's
just kind of a
it's proof that you're doing your job
and the [ __ ] that came out of this
woman's mouth i
never heard now when you approach a
novel like that when you have a story
like that that's brewing your head
how do you decide what to pull the
trigger on
like do you just go on instinct did you
just have a concept in your head
and it just seems more and more
attractive and you just say okay this is
it
you know one really good test is if you
can take it to a party
and you can tell a very small part of it
as much of it as you know at that point
and people will
vie for a chance to relate some aspect
of their life
that is very much like that but an even
more extreme example of that
so in a way they're they're fleshing out
your theme
with parts of their own lives and so you
find yourself drawing from the
experience of
dozens or hundreds or thousands of
people
and at the same time you're beta testing
it you're kind of taking it on the road
and you're seeing that it's an idea that
res resonates
with a huge number of people that
everyone can relate to it
hmm that's interesting so do you
purposely like go to parties
with like uh a couple like bullets in
the chamber
sometimes or sometimes i just go to the
party and i listen
to hear somebody tell that that personal
anecdote
that does evoke all those other
anecdotes
because a great anecdote doesn't leave
people speechless it leaves them
competing
to tell a better version of the same
thing
and that's when a real writer just
starts realizing okay there's a pattern
and that can be turned into something
really big that's really interesting
working jobs we hate so we can buy [ __ ]
we don't need
my classic thing is that there are so
few social model novels
or stories for men for women
there are us you know every season
there's a new joy luck club a new how to
make an american quilt a new
traveling sisterhood of the yaya pants
whatever just all these different models
in which
women can come together and talk about
their lives
and if you're a man you've got either
fight club or you have the dead poet
society
and that is really it so we don't have a
lot of narratives
that that depict to men a role or a kind
of script
in which to come together and talk about
their their shed
another thing is jordan peterson back to
jordan peterson he talks about
that need for really rough play you know
we've kind of fallen away from this idea
of consensual rough play
and i think fight club resonated with
that a lot
and also the idea of joseph campbell's
idea
that there needs to be a secondary
father in men's lives
that you're born if you're lucky with a
biological father that you do not choose
and that is the the nurturing loving
father that you eventually kind of have
to reject
but in doing so you have to choose a new
father
and that that father by choice typically
is a
a minister or a teacher or a drill
sergeant or a coach
one of those fathers and you kind of put
yourself in apprenticeship
to the secondary father and you have to
sort of consign your life to the
secondary father
and agree to learn what they're going to
teach you
just like in karate kid and that is
getting
harder and harder and harder to find so
fight club was also depicting a new form
of the secondary father
with all these these kids that were
showing up on the doorstep
of this ramshackle old house so there
was just so many aspects
of men's lives that were not being
addressed
when fight club came out and it sort of
reinvented so many of those things that
had fallen by the wayside trust me
everything's gonna be fine
you